لم يعد هذا المشهد حاله استثنائيه في
شوارع بغداد
وازمه المرور لم تعد حاله عابره بل اصبحت
امرا واقعا وجزءا من يوميات البغداديين
[موسيقى]
تقول دائره المرور ان عدد السيارات في
العاصمه العراقيه يقارب اربعه ملايين
سياره وهو ما يفوق طاقتها الاستيعابيه
بنحو عشره اضعاف نشوف هناك زياده نسبيه في
عدد السكان يجب اتخاذ اجراءات يجب تحط في
كل شيء هو بس بالمرور لاجانب الصحي جانب
التعليمي توفير المدى يجب التخطيط لها
الدراسه يجب ان تتلامع الحلوى ايجاد
الحدود مين ايجاد الحدود من من يخطط ايجاد
الحلول
تظهر ارقام وزاره التخطيط ان عدد سكان
بغداد ارتفع كثيرا في العقدين الماضيين
ووصل الى تسعه ملايين نسمه وهو ما يزيد عن
خمس سكان البلاد الذين تضاعف عددهم اكثر
من ثلاث مرات خلال اربعه عقود
شكلت الهجره نحو المركز والبحث عن فرص عمل
اضافه الى غياب وتغيب القوانين المنظمه
للهجره من الريف الى المدينه
عوامل رئيسيه لهذه الزياده التي يرى
معنيون انها اصبحت تشكل خطرا على وضع
المدينه المعماري والخدمي كل
البنيه معرضه للضغط متزايد ومستمر اذا ما
يصير عمليه التخفيف هذا الضغط
بحلول هندسيه ملائمه ومناسبه قد تصل في
الوضع حقيقه صعب الوصف
مثلا ظاهره التوسع المعماري على حساب
المناطق الزراعيه في بغداد احد مظاهر هذه
الازمه توسع حذر كثيرون من نتائجه السلبيه
على البيئه كما تسببت الازمه في ضغط كبير
على قطاع الخدمات بالمدينه التي صممت
لاستيعاب النحو ثلاثه ملايين سنه ولم تشهد
بناها التحتيه في كل القطاعات تطورا
حقيقيا منذ ثمانينيات القرن الماضي يقول
معنيون ان حل مشكله ارتفاع اعاده السكان
في بغداد لا يزال متاحا لكنه يحتاج الى
اجراءات حقيقيه وسريعه
تبدا بوقف الهجره الى المدينه ولا تنتهي
عند التوسع الافقي للاراضي السكنيه وليد
ابراهيم الجزيره بغداد